sur l' iss ou sur la lune on a des
intérêts au niveau du de recherche et
développement de nouvelles techniques de
nouvelles techniques qui peuvent
peut-être nous apprendre à vivre de
manière plus autre plus avec moins de
dépenses d'énergie et moins dé meilleur
recyclage en fait sur terre ça permet
aussi toutes sortes de compréhension
physiologique au niveau de la
physiologie du corps humain il ya
énormément d'expérience qui sont faites
sur l'ia c'est ce qu'ils tiennent à ça
et qui peuvent permettre de mieux
comprendre comment comment soigner
certaines maladies sur terre qui sont
des choses que rencontrent les
astronautes quand ils sont soumis à la
microgravité et aux radiations
donc je pense qu'à ce niveau là il ya
des intérêts évidents d'avoir une
présence dans l'espace mais maintenant
pour moi c'est ça a un sens dans
l'espace proche c'est à dire justement
l'allier cesse la lune éventuellement
quand on parle d'aller au delà je pense
que les coûts et les problèmes que sa
rencontre dépasse largement les
bénéfices qu'on peut en escompter il
peut imaginer que un vol habité d'après
les estimations budgétaires qui sont
faites actuellement avec avec cet argent
là on peut envoyer 40 persévérance et
quand on voit à quel point les sont
différentes successives se sont
améliorées ont permis des dîmes des
avancées de la compréhension de mars par
exemple justement et de sa géologie de
son évolution du climat et toutes sortes
de choses comme ça on peut se dire que
voilà on envoyait 40 ça va être de toute
façon un bénéfice bien supérieur à un
vol habité
et même si l'intérêt d'avoir le cerveau
et les mains au même endroit au même
moment est souvent émis comme comme
comme de raison d'envoyer des gens
là-bas pour l'exploration de mars
je doute que ça arrive à l'entrée en
compétition avec 40 missions robotiques
qui seront toutes plus plus
perfectionnés en fait les unes que les
autres
[Musique]